theillet big flo et oli squeeze cristal
avec les mots twitter jamais deux sans
trois jamais alain syndicaux jamais sans
moi je met au lit sans big flo nouvelle
mission j'entends sous les monts bipper
un freestyle avec squeeze des mots
choisis sur twitter le tueur de pige pas
des records comme un slot in open text
au fils dans une ville où il pleut des
cordes et 0 conservatoire j'étais au
fond du réfectoire je vais devoir
regarder le monde d'abondance abattoir
mais dans les foires trop se sont fait
avoir
moi je fais les super fête à troyes le
rythme est superfétatoire je suis plein
de paradoxes et ça laisse mes conneries
et du albert einstein at-on
phénylcétonurie freestyle avec amour
tous vos mots compliqués souvent cruel
cabourg mais je suis qu'un foutriquet
noms sont regroupés sur ses pas de
l'asthme et quand je dis que je suis
mauvais c'est juste une mauvaise mais
quand je prends le mcee pas photo le
mauvais rap est abolie tu bouges la tête
surtout mais flo et toi je gratte ça va
trop vite n'importe quel mot genre pas
grave c'est de la folie
j'en ris à cause des combats et des
phobies et jamais deux sans toi si tu la
chute est pas mal
sur toi on m'a offert le dictionnaire a
reconnu devoir jongler avec les mots
encore c'est squeeze au leap x pour
faire des galipettes sur le canapé je
cherche une fille callipyge et prcg
beaucoup succès je suis plus le même
qu'à dix piges
méfie-toi de l'eau qui dort à peine j'ai
trop de flou chez le premier rappeur
anadyomène tu es un stéréotype 28ème
vieux type tellement de tesselles fils
ebitda guériot thibout a sursauté draft
crif est pas le fut chaud thé et la nuit
dans mon livre mais a chuchoté j'avais
pleuré
j'ouvre un bar tabac je suis le genre de
gars qui s'est pas tapé va les masques
tu peux enlever ton mascara j'arrive de
nulle part comme le mascaret monte le
son mon frérot écoutez profite
loin des zones morceau beaucoup plus
prolixe visible flo et oli bien d'où tu
connais par coeur chalut nos pentax au
fil donc je suis toujours à leur écoute
meriem encore cède à la tentation jeu
transformé mon en orge de la
transsubstantiation le dernier bri bâle
y aura pas de nouvel opus mindaf avec la
main d'un terry sino-russe jamais deux
sans trois si tu l'as eu des
visionnaires pas
sans toi on a ouvert le dictionnaire
d'argot du devoir on jongle avec les
mots tout le monde
une fois ces jeux quizz et olympic sans
suite ou l' inverse d'un réseau morphée
chelsea fébrile j'avoue qu'en soirée je
suis le mec klepis évident tu prennes un
fan pour des clients ils les fidélise
ils veulent des bijoux pour huit ans ici
mais c'est ce film on tarde de masques
tombent
c'est juste antipathique j'écrirai faire
des études frigorigènes et inexpugnable
donc surveillent des arrières au fait on
met qu'une âme fallait pas rendre la
tienne les tours sont durs les facteurs
son décès ça fait trois mots de travers
dans un tweet les sept ans j'étais fan
de laurie non-stop dans l'euphorie
aujourd'hui tout me fait chier
j'embrasse radio mauritanienne et des
éléments je crois magnifique lutte
musclée dit on est passé qui tape pas ce
qui se passe entre le p tit chochoy bien
que la hem et merci au lit et big lots
c'est la fin d'un beau bébé de 3 si tu
l'as eu des légionnaires pas mal à
chantois on a ouvert le dictionnaire
d'argot connue non droit
on jongle avec les mots tout le monde
encore une fois c'est squeeze olympics
au monde encore une fois c'est squeeze
ory big flo
[Applaudissements]